so another three weeks of lockdown in
the UK it says a very big decision but
what's the data that underlies it we can
give you a sense of what's going on in
the UK by having a look at some of these
numbers you've probably familiar with
this chart already showing you the death
tolls in various different countries
around the world a very depressing shot
it's a logarithmic chart so essentially
the steeper these lines are the faster
those rates are growing because this is
a neck disease that spreads that
exponentially we'll get on to that in a
second but focusing on the UK in
particular we now know we're up to
thirteen thousand seven hundred
twenty-nine deaths in hospitals so
that's in hospitals it's a terrible
number but as I say it would have been a
lot higher had growth rates continued
the way they were early on after the
lockdown they have come down quite a bit
and I'll show you a chart that
illustrates that in a moment but that's
just hospital deaths we're now also
getting a sense of what's going on
elsewhere around the country and care
homes in private homes and the
government has just produced this data
series showing you all deaths in all
settings it's not very timely so it's
kind of a bit out of date but what you
can see is that line is above the
hospital death number and so what that
means is the picture we're getting every
day from the government is an
understatement it's understating the
true number of people who are dying and
we won't know for quite some time what
the grand total is except that it is
much higher than anyone would like as I
say though these lines are cumulative
totals but they don't really show you
when the numbers start to fall very well
so I've got a different way of showing
that basically it's it's daily deaths
it's a 7-day average for all these
different countries and let me give you
a consensus of what we're talking about
by looking just in particular at the UK
you can see that line is starting to
flatten so the number of people dying if
a seven-day average so smooth it out is
now basically pretty flat and in
countries like Italy in Spain you can
see it's actually come down from the
peak in those countries but there is
definitely a place that stands out and
having a very different story and have a
look this is the US and look at that
line rather than flattening like there's
other countries it's continuing to rise
and as I say these are logarithmic
charts if you had a normal job with a
normal access you'd see that kind of
going up
into the roof so a very big increase in
the u.s. still at the moment but it
isn't just these lines that their
scientists are looking at when they're
deciding about lockdowns it's also other
indications it's this statistic in
particular the are number of
reproduction rate of for the disease and
just how many people it is being passed
on to on average so initially the
modelers said that it was about 2.6 so
every one person who got the disease 2.6
people would get it from then they'd be
infected so you go from 1 to 3 to 9
potentially and before long you're
talking about tens of thousands hundreds
of thousands even that's what we mean
when we talk about an exponential
increase in this and the good news is
that the modelers that say to think that
they've that it has got down to below
one and why is that important well look
at the lines look at the number of
people who potentially get infected here
those whites people it's just one them
one them one you're not getting that
exponential T the big spread in the
disease you might have had before that's
not everything though according to Sir
Patrick valence the social distancing
measure that in place need to stay in
place in order to reduce the numbers of
people with the infection in the
community that allows the I mean that's
because the R comes down but it's also
the absolute number that needs to come
down so we've got fewer people carrying
the infection now in some countries like
Germany they're doing a lot of testing
and that's important because it gives
you a sense of what that our number is
if you're not testing you don't have as
much of a sense of that and then the UK
they said that they were going to get up
to 100,000 tests a day but look at where
they are the top of that axis it's
100,000 and you can see we're still down
at around actually below 20,000 tests a
day so potentially the government really
needs to to get those numbers up so that
it can get a sense of what's the our
number is and decide on the next phase
of the lockdown and that matters for
everyone because this isn't just about
public health it's also about the
economy and have a look at this chart
showing you unemployment claims across
the economy over the course of the last
few decades oh it goes all the way back
actually to 1983 so you've got the early
1980s recession black Wednesday 1992
you've got the financial crisis there
look at the spike recently the covert 19
spike on universal credits claims is
higher than any other period since the
creation of the welfare state it
underlines how much trouble the economy
is how much pain people are feeling
financially and the longer the lockdown
goes on for the bigger the problem there